I've had a really interesting life but
the life started as being a little girl
waiting in line to see the first Star
Wars on this very Street at that very
theater this day means more to me than
you could possibly imagine just months
after Christina Applegate received her
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame she's
hinting her decades-long acting career
might be over amid her battle with
multiple sclerosis how do I deal with
everything in life
um I take I try to be really present
present and grateful the actress tells
the Los Angeles Times the upcoming SAG
Awards is quote my last award show as an
actor probably so it's kind of a big
deal fans last Saw Christina at the
Critics Choice Awards in January where
she was nominated for her work in dead
to me now I know why you love this car
right the event was Christina's first
award show since 2019 and the first
since her Ms diagnosis in 2021 which
happened while she was filming the
Netflix shows final season
shooting the show was the hardest thing
I'd ever done in my life I didn't know
what was happening to me I I couldn't
walk I they had to use a wheelchair to
get me to set
um I was freaking out until someone was
like you need an MRI and then I found
out on a Monday after work that I had Ms
you know a disease that I'm going to
have for the rest of my life but despite
her struggles Christina's dead to me
co-star James Marsden was simply in all
of her strength to push through it it
was a challenge but she's a warrior and
she just hit it head on and she's she's
working through it but she's you know
she's a battler and she you know she's
getting through it the show took a
backseat to her health for sure she's a
tough one she really is what are you
doing
but it seems Christina's acting career
is now taking a back seat quote right
now I couldn't imagine getting up at 5am
and spending 12 to 14 hours on a set I
don't have that in me at this moment to
like reach out there and to entertain
people has been the most exhilarating
thing and Christina has no plans of
stopping that because she's considering
a future behind the scenes doing a ton
of voice-overs to make some cash to make
sure that my daughter's fed and we're
home
foreign